- [Instructor] What we're
going to do in this video
is get some practice estimating adding
and subtracting three digit numbers
and so here it says 398 plus 251 is,
and this squiggly equal sign means
we just need to make an estimate.
We wanna know what is
this roughly equal to?
So normally I say pause the video
but here I want you to
work it out in your head.
So I'm just gonna pause.
I'm just gonna stop
talking for like a second
and see if you can come
up with what this is
or maybe I'll give you three seconds
'cause the whole point
here is to estimate,
not get the exact right answer.
Okay, so I'm assuming
you've had a go at it.
Now, I'll tell you how I think about it.
We of course could maybe
take out some paper
or you might even be able to get
the exact answer in your head
but in everyday life, if
you're at the supermarket
and you're like, okay,
I guess it would be an
expensive supermarket,
something is $398, something else is $251.
Roughly how much would I be spending
if I bought both of them?
Well, my head would say, alright,
398, I would round to nearest 10 at least,
maybe the nearest 100.
So let's round to the nearest 10.
In the case of 398, the
nearest 10 is the nearest 100.
And so we would get to,
this is approximately 400.
And then this is, 251
is approximately 250.
So if you were to add these two things up,
you're going to get something
that is approximately equal to 650.
And lucky for us, that
is one of the choices
and what I'm about to do is not estimate
but just see how far off we were.
So if we were to just
actually do it, 398 plus 251.
Eight plus one is nine.
Nine plus five is 14.
This is 14 10s.
We put four 10s here,
and the other 10 10s we regroup as 100
and then one plus three plus 200 is 600.
So in this case, in this particular case,
we got awfully close with our estimation
and if you don't need
to get the exact number,
well, that'll be fine.
Let's do another example.
In here, we are going to do
a little bit of subtraction.
So once again, pause this video
or try to do it as quickly as you can.
Try to estimate what this
difference is going to be.
678 minus 273.
Alright, let's do it together.
So there's a couple of ways to tackle it.
You could round to the nearest 10
and you could say, well,
this is approximately 600,
let's see, to round to the nearest 10,
you would round up right over here
so you'd say this is 680 minus
you could say 270
which is going to give you
and here you're still gonna
have to do some mental math.
This would be what?
600 minus 200 is 400
and 80 minus 70 is 10.
So that's one way to do it
or you could do it even rougher.
You could just do to the nearest 100.
So you could say, look, 678,
the nearest 100 is 700
and then minus 273, the
nearest 100 there is 300
and so this is even rougher
but it gets us actually
still similar answers
and either way we estimated,
either the kind of rougher way
or the slightly less rough way,
we got to something around 400.
So you could feel good
that this is your choice.
The reason why we even have to make
multiple choice questions for estimation
is not everyone is gonna
get the exact same estimate
but the correct choice should be the one
that any reasonable estimate
would be closest to.